peu
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ce que c'est mignon de ces petites bêtes
j'ai pas le palais sera au chaud
vivement la halle le boeuf
les pas de chahut
tout ce que j'ai trouvé qu'un bruit vous
avec ça
[Musique]
tu mid middle
allez ça sera quand même plus
confortable cette sortie
[Musique]
on
au bond
ça va au japon
[Musique]
bon
sera pas si me cherchais quelqu'un j'ai
peur de me laisse pas seulement temps tu
veux bien
[Musique]
enfin
non
dans ma femme attend un enfant arrêt sap
reste
ah bon ben c'est pas une critique ici
sur le battoir quelque chose appeler
quelqu'un je prendre un billet pas
tarder à ce soir c'est noël police
[Applaudissements]
mademoiselle vous êtes la clinique c'est
pour les abattoirs
j'étais en train de réveillonner bien
tranquille et tout d'un coup patatras y
voyez vous un enfant pas moi je suis
célibataire
alors je les avais mis dans un petit
coin bien propre comprenez avec ses
bêtes c'est pas grave
et justement il va y avoir un enfant
parler dans les chefs phone c'est pour
les abattoirs
je vous comprenez moi je peux rien faire
j'étais en train de réveillonner bien
tranquille et à lui le mari qui vient me
dire ah bah moi que l sa femme elle
attend un enfant un bébé quoi
ainsi pour une urgence
[Musique]
non
à
[Musique]
or
enfin
[Musique]
à
je voudrais pas me mêler de ce qui me
regarde pas mais peut-être ce serait
mieux de demander à un médecin
le médecin il est chez l'académicien jeu
progrès en matière de techniques tout
spécialement formés à disserter d'autres
vieux continent
[Musique]
avons nous aviez aimé pourtant notre
guerrier toujours belle héros
[Musique]
avion
nous devrons un autre tour nous
contenter d'imiter les exsangue qui nous
[Musique]
japonais
faudrait être aujourd'hui
m
[Musique]
mécanique
on
ce versement est vraiment mauvais
et là vous évidemment sa lettre donnée
la femme du maroc
allez tu peux appeler un 24 décembre à
minuit à l'eau aux abattoirs un médecin
un petit enfant sur la paille
entre un boeuf et un homme sur votre
cher ça me désole les voir enfin une
naissance à noël font des cadeaux allons
aussi qu'elle dit
nous avons pris les paquets et nous
voilà partis en chantant dansant nous
avons fait le chemin
le ch et l'académicien aux abattoirs de
vaugirard il pleuvait sur les capsules
chapeau malgré tout nous étions de bonne
humeur toi je voudrais toujours rire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui
c'est tout bus
ça c'est quoi
[Musique]
car il
le propos
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais où est ce qu'ils vont mais sont
faussés réveillonneurs c'est la fin du
monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
si parce que j'oublie
elle avait là
m
[Musique]
charmant charme et puis ya même du pain
tiens vague où j'étais à pau ce top 20
sont gentils photographe sait jamais
c'est peut-être là quelque part
ah ouais ce n'était pas une nuit
ordinaire mais ce n'est pas fini
dans tous les contes de noël il ya un
miracle
et l'histoire ne s'arrête pas là au
petit matin les bougies éteintes les
réveillonneurs coucher et mirax epr et
âge tu donnes pas le sauveur pour le
boss donne le plus grand chose à faire
sûrement pas c'est le moment de lancer
un appel radio
alou abattoirs appelé spa est louée
sperme entendez-vous alors oui je vous
écoute mais je vous entends très mal
parler plus fort je vous prie gabriel
autres modèles sauf s'il vous plaît j'ai
de bon sens fait vite c'est déjà l'aube
vous savez ce que ça veut dire
ici le travail commence de très bonne
heure
les grilles sont déjà ouvertes les
tables sont prêtes les couteaux affûtés
si vous ne venez pas c'est la fin
bon on déclenche le dispositif d'urgence
le dispositif miracle de noël nous
arrivons tout de suite plus vite et
royal pardon
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on
[Musique]
bon
où
en vous
[Musique]
non
et oui vous s'est défendu d' hommes et
les bêtes ou avec cet ami ray
un miracle
[Musique]
très bien gabriel
la maison
[Musique]
on va
on voit
pas ça
enfin
vous
[Musique]
oh
on
on peut
[Musique]
le
où
e
le
[Musique]